[MUSIC PLAYING]
LUCIEN AVRAMOV:
My name is Lucien.
I'm one of the PMs working on
our Velostrata product that's
now called Anthos Migrate.
And I'm joined today with
two other gentlemen that
will come on stage later on.
We have our architect
and technical lead
for this product, Leonid,
that's here with us.
And we have David, who is the
product manager for Service
Mesh and Istio as well.
So during the next 50 minutes,
what we'd like to tell
you about is Anthos
Migrate, what it is,
and how we will enable you to
migrate on-premise type of VMs
workloads to Cloud-Native,
and how to take you
through the GKE journey.
So that's the goal of what we
want to achieve in the next 50
minutes together.
And I'll be leading the
first part of our talk,
and then we'll go
over and deep dive.
Before I start, what I'd
like to clarify is naming
and what things are because
we made some announcements
two days ago the keynote.
And what I wanted to make
sure everyone understands is
that the product called
Anthos Migrate now,
that we decided
to call that way,
is actually our
Velostrata technology.
That's a Google product.
And it's the same thing.
So if some of you are
familiar with Velostrata,
migration of VM to
VM, lift and shift,
now we have a new
functionality where we also
migrate to containers, to GKE.
And both of these
Velostrata functions
are called Anthos Migrate.
So it's the same thing, and
I hope this clears it up.
Here's the agenda for
the next 48 minutes.
I'll go over, first,
some of the whys--
why we want to do what we're
doing, what are the goals,
and what's the reason
of our technology.
Then I'll go on to
product overview.
After that, I'll
hand it off to David,
who will be talking
about service management.
And finally, we'll
have Leonid that
will go over that architecture.
So more technically,
Leonid will explain
what's happening with
the migration process,
and he will guide you
on the architecture
deep dive of the product.
All right.
So without further
ado, why do we
want to move VM workloads
to run as containers on GKE?
Why is it compelling?
First of all, migration
is a difficult task.
Migration is hard.
Most enterprises
trying to migrate
realize how difficult it is.
They face delays, budgets,
and stuff like that,
so it's a hard thing to do.
And when we poll on
different surveys,
it's top of mind for customers.
And actually, I'll do a
poll here in the room.
Can I get a raise of
hand on how many of
you would like to move
to the cloud, this room?
OK.
About a third.
How many of you
want to move to GKE?
Wow.
OK.
And GKE on-premise?
Some.
OK.
So for those of you
that want to move,
I hope this session makes sense.
And for the other ones,
I'd like to take you
on board so you
understand our technology,
so when these topics
come top of mind,
you know best what
Google can offer
you to migrate you and
take you to that journey.
So challenges, it's hard.
The scale, you
have data centers,
and you have workloads.
You have thousands of VMs
that you may need to move.
You have multi different
places, different locations,
and you're wondering
what to aggregate.
The applications sometimes
run on multiple places.
Which app do you select?
Which one can you move?
And how then do
you start doing it?
And it's complex.
Also, the applications
are complex,
and you have to understand
what's happening behind there.
And then lastly, the risk.
We oftentimes talk
about migration,
but we don't often talk
about rolling back.
What happens if you
start to migrate
and things don't go well?
Well, you'd like to go
back to your initial state
without losing data so you can
roll back and then figure it
out and try again later.
With our technology, we can
provide you that back and forth
at any time.
So you can run
on-premise, migrate,
if something happens
you can come back.
And we have multiple ways
of doing that migration.
So why now do we want to
modernize our workloads
to containers?
Well, there's two main things.
One is, we have customers--
and about a third in this room
knows this-- that want to
modernize legacy applications.
So the idea is, well,
I'd like to move
certain parts to the
cloud because it's more
cost efficient.
It makes more sense.
It will be closer to a
development environment,
and I'm developing some
new app on the cloud,
and I'd like to move some
legacy apps over there
as well to be able to interact
with my applications that
are running on the cloud.
I'd like to modernize my
application management
lifecycle and have
a consistent way
to do maintenance,
patching, and so forth.
So that's one.
The second one on
this slide is GKE.
So GKE is our offering
for Kubernetes,
and a lot of our
customers love GKE.
And so that's a
compelling reason
to move to Google or
to GCP in general.
And so we can take
you to that framework,
from a traditional enterprise
VM place to take you to GKE.
Once you're there, you'll
see the benefits of GKE,
so management of your images,
OS, interaction with logging,
interaction with service
meshes, and Istio.
And so those are
things we'll talk
about today in terms
of your benefits
as when you move to the cloud.
Before I forget, we also
have a Dory today open.
So if any of you have
a question at any time,
feel free to raise your hand
or type a question on the Dory,
and we'll come back to the
Dory we have along here
that's monitoring our Dory.
And we will get back
to your questions.
So we talked about
why we're doing it.
Now, why is it hard?
Why is it hard to move
from a VM environment
to GKE specifically?
Well, when you
have a legacy app,
to move into a
microservices environment
you have to rewrite
it in a modern way
and oftentimes go from a,
obviously, stateful type
of application to
think about how you're
going to make it stateless.
And so that is actually,
really, a difficult thing to do.
You have to re-build
your application.
Many of the old applications
don't have that type
of knowledge of application
logic and just cannot go
into being stateless.
So it's something hard and
oftentimes, it's not possible.
However, your new applications
that you're developing,
they are modern, they interact,
they're containerized.
And so then comes the
point of, well, I'd
like these new
applications that I'm
deploying to also be able to
interact with the other ones
and to have a
consistent way to manage
my infrastructure, my workloads,
by being on containers
on a container framework.
And this is why--
the second point
is, why not just
do a lift and shift,
or just move a VM
to be a VM moving to the cloud?
You can do that, and we
offer that technology.
We know how to do it at scale.
We have customers moving
thousands and thousands of VMs
in lift and shift,
where the source is a VM
and the destination is a VM.
But the new thing that,
here, we're talking about
is the source is a VM and the
destination is a container.
And finally, when you're
there, basically it's
us adapting to your journey,
to your environment.
And how can we help you
going to a modern framework
on containers and
at the same time
enable you to move
these legacy app
and still keep the lights
on for these apps to run
but being managed in the
modern infrastructure.
So with that, I'm going to
go ahead and move and talk
about our product overview.
So what is Anthos Migrate?
How does it work?
And then we'll move
further on the next topic.
So first, I'd like to ask
in the room, how many of you
know Kubernetes?
Can I get a raise of hand?
Majority.
OK.
Great.
So we'll go quickly
over this one.
Portable, open-source
management platform,
allowing you to scale,
to run, basically
to orchestrate your containers
and to run them with policy,
declarative model, and be able
to run on various clusters,
various environments.
So initially, our
internal systems obviously
run on Kubernetes,
and now we do it
with managed to Kubernetes,
GKE, where we actually
take care of managing
the kernel for you,
providing you upgrades,
security patches, fixes.
And so our SRE teams operate
the management of the kernel
and OS for you
when you are on GKE
versus running
Kubernetes by yourself
on an open-source model.
So as we know GKE,
I'll move forward.
So at this point,
we're at a place where
you have applications,
hopefully, that
are VMs in a data center,
you know the value of GKE,
and you want to
modernize these apps
or you want these
apps to be able to run
in that new modern environment.
So then, what do you do?
Then comes this
product, Anthos Migrate.
OK.
And here is, at a
glance, what we do.
You start-- and the
way to read the slide,
we'll go on the left-hand
side of the slide.
I'd like you to read
it from bottom, up.
OK?
So at the bottom,
what you see is
that we have different
sources of environments.
You can be on premise, you
can be on a public cloud,
and you have, as a starting
point, a virtual machine.
Your destination is
up on this slide,
which is the GCP platform.
And where you end
up is basically
on containers running
on GKE, and then you
have other services-- service
mesh-- that come and attach
themselves to that.
So all the ecosystem
of the GCP platform
come, and then can interact
with your GKE cluster
once you've done that move.
OK.
So we can do VMware.
We can do physical bare metal.
We can do other cloud
type of migration,
and the source is
a virtual machine.
Here is how this works.
And for you to understand
Anthos Migrate,
there's two things that
you need to understand.
One is understand GKE
and understand GCP.
And this is new.
This can be new when you
are in an enterprise or a VM
environment and you're
moving to the cloud.
So one aspect to know
is containers and GKE
and how GKE works.
And the second part is the
Anthos Migrate Velostrata
technology.
And so we intersect
at these two.
And the way we've
designed this is
to give you the journey and
experience of Kubernetes.
So how do we start the journey?
You're a user, and
you're over here,
and you want to
go on containers.
So the way you will
do that is basically,
you're going to do
a deployment policy.
You will have a YAML
file, which is Kubernetes,
and you will tell GKE that
you want to start a migration.
So actually, you
start your migration
by talking to GKE versus going
on your on-premise environment.
And so you push the YAML file,
and then what GKE will do,
GKE integrates with our
Anthos Migrate technology.
And then we start the
migration of the VM.
So you have these
VMs that you see here
that are running in
your data center,
and we've received from
Kubernetes, from GKE,
we received the
instructions to migrate,
and then Velostrata Anthos
Migrate starts the migration.
So you have these
two blue VMs that
are running on your data center,
and where we move is over here.
You end up with two containers.
So I did a one-on-one
mapping, just to show you
the example, the visual example
where you have two VMs running
on premise, and the end result
is two containers running
on GKE.
And it's all
orchestrated by GKE.
And so that's really
important concept to know.
Now, with that, I'll tell
you a little bit more
under the hood in terms of
how we enable this migration.
So I'll just move to this slide.
We have, basically, here,
our Velostrata Anthos Migrate
technology resides
into two places.
One is on premise, we have
a Velostrata appliance,
which is a VM, running
on one of your vCenter
which is basically our back end.
And we have an ESX plug-in,
so a plug-in for VMware
that will basically give
you the manageability
and the interaction with the
virtual machines over there.
So that's one part
of the deployment.
So you install that on your
on-premise environment.
Number two, on the cloud we have
running our management software
for Velostrata.
So install that
through Marketplace.
You install it as a
VM running, and you
connect to your on-prem.
Between the two,
we assume that you
have IP connectivity between
your on-premise environment
and your GCP cluster.
That can be achieved by a VPC.
That can be achieved
by an interconnect.
But you have to have IP
connectivity between your two
environments.
We create, then, a local
cache on the cloud.
And what we do is--
now, listen to this.
We have a VM running, and
we started the migration.
In 5 to 10 minutes, depending
if it's Linux or Windows,
your new environment will be
up and running on the cloud.
The way we do it is,
we start the new VM
or the new container,
so I'm talking
of two use cases, either the
VM to VM or VM to container.
We fire up the new
container, for example.
The data initially is still
residing on your on premise,
and is being streamed
over your IP connection
to the new environment.
And that data is
getting cached locally.
The cache grows, and you can
start testing your application.
You can start using
it right away.
You don't need to wait for
all the data, all the disk,
to be migrated for you to
know if your application will
start working on the cloud.
And we achieve that with
our streaming Anthos Migrate
technology.
And you benefit
from that technology
whether you do VM to VM
migration or VM to containers
migration.
If things don't go
well, you can roll back.
We also have ways for
you to do testing.
So if you are running
production in your environment,
we can actually
make a copy and get
you to test a clone of
that VM on the cloud,
so it's less disruptive.
And then we give you the way
to migrate at [INAUDIBLE] later
on production environments.
So if you want to migrate
hundreds, thousands of VMs,
you can do that on a schedule
with automation tools
that we provide.
So that's how the
whole migration
is working under the hood.
Next, now that you
are with containers,
for example, where
do you see your logs?
So on your VM,
initially you go and you
have to look at log files
and understand error messages
and so forth.
We have integrated the logs from
your VMs with Stackdriver with
the GKE Dashboard and,
more importantly--
and David will be
telling you about this--
with service management.
And so you basically
can see your logs
as you would see logs from--
you see your log outputs here
in the Stackdriver output.
And so you can
interact with APIs,
with monitoring management
tools if you have,
but it is a modern
GCP native display.
Same goes with
the GKE dashboard.
OK.
You can see what your app is
doing, how much CPU it's using,
and so forth.
Now, the next point
is, well, what
can you migrate to containers?
What really can
you do if you are
ready to migrate your
VM to containers?
What we're doing is, basically,
Linux operating systems today.
We don't support
yet Windows, Windows
because we don't want you to
have Windows on containers.
So it has to be Linux.
It has to be Red Hat,
CentOS, SUSE, Ubuntu--
those are the main
operating systems--
Tomcat, Apache,
Websphere, Weblogic,
JBoss type of middleware
applications, databases.
So all of these legacy
type of stateful workloads
you can migrate to GKE.
Certain things that
we don't yet do
because, what we announced was
our beta that we're working
on now on this product,
we don't want you
get to move production.
We don't want you to
move sensitive data
because we're on a private
beta at the moment.
And the other thing we don't do
is high performance databases,
such as Hadoop, big
data type of workloads.
And here, for
transparency purposes,
we've outlined the things we
support, we don't support.
Keep in mind that the product is
evolving, roadmap and so forth.
So if there are things
that you'd like to get,
come talk to us at the booths.
Come meet us today.
Talk to your field
representatives,
and we can work with you
to prioritize things.
This is just to
give you a framework
so you can understand
if it's something that's
applicable to you right away.
With that, I'd like to
give you a little demo,
just so you can
visualize the product.
So let's go ahead and try
to play this recording.
So while this loads I
just want to prepare you.
It's a CRM application.
So it's basically going to be
a web app that has the database
and customer base CRM.
And it's going to be two VMs.
So I have it running as two
different virtual machines
on VMware.
One is a database, and one is
the web server in application.
And we'll migrate these two
VMs from on-premise to GKE.
OK.
And here we're
going to play this.
And we can spend a
lot more time with you
if you stop by our booth.
We can show you the demo live.
Here, for purpose of
time and everything,
I just want to play a recording
so it just gets things going,
so you see the concepts.
But then we can spend more
time on the live demo.
So as you see, we have,
as I said, two VMs.
One is running on CentOS and the
other one is running on SUSE.
So I have two different
operating systems as a start,
and that's my CRM app
running on premise.
So two VMs, two OSs.
I can log in.
And what you see here when
I log in on the local IP
is the look of the app.
I have a GKE
cluster called Demo,
which is running a
specific version of GKE.
And I have, basically,
a YAML file.
Remember, I told you that we
started the migration from YAML
from Kubernetes, so we have
a file where we say, look,
this is the VM number.
We want to use streaming for
our Velostrata technology,
and we want to do, here,
a test plan, for example.
We point to a persistent disk,
and we define the app name
and the way it will
look once it's migrated
on the destination environment.
And so we're going to go ahead
and execute the YAML file.
It's at the very bottom here.
We do a kubectl apply.
And basically what
you see, we refresh
Services and Workloads,
here is basically now two--
you can see the two
nodes, app and database,
and you can see the services.
We have a load bouncer with
a local IP on the cloud,
and we login onto that
IP, and it's the same app.
Now that app has moved and is
running as containers on GKE.
Then we go in and we
enable Istio as an add-on
onto our cluster.
Now when we do that, basically,
we can go in Stackdriver,
and we can see data.
We can see the graphs.
And a lot more
things we can do is
going to be what David is going
to talk to you about next,
which is service mesh, which
will be added functions of what
you do once you are
on GKE and you've
migrated our application.
So with that, Dave, I'd like
to call you up and take it away
for us.
And I'll put it back
in presentation mode.
DAVID MUNRO: So first of
all, thank you Lucien.
So I just actually want
to recap because one
of the things that's
really amazing there is--
I don't know whether you just
realized what you've witnessed,
but you literally
witnessed a VM application
on premise migrating
live, directly to GKE.
So I think that's actually
pretty amazing, personally.
I think that actually
gives you an opportunity,
and this is something
that you can
do while your
applications are running.
So I think that's actually
a pretty big thing.
When Lucien asked before
around the number of people
who understand or
know what GKE is,
it was a very, very
large number of people.
So the other thing that we
talk about a lot from a Google
perspective is Istio
and service mesh.
So Istio is an
open-source project.
It was founded primarily
by IBM and Google.
There is a large number
of contributors now--
Cisco, VMware, Red Hat.
There are a large number of
people contributing to Istio,
and we're getting a lot
of community support.
So this is actually
something that we're actually
investing quite heavily in.
And we think this is a natural
extension for both Kubernetes
and non-Kubernetes environments.
But also, it gives
you the ability
to do things from a service
management perspective
that you may not necessarily--
it reduces the need for you
to instrument your code,
and you can take
advantage of those things
effectively out of the box.
So one of the
things that we talk
about would be, let's do
the migration that you just
saw but do that into a service
mesh enabled GKE cluster.
By doing that, you
can actually take
advantage of some of the
service management capabilities
that you get from a
service mesh from day one.
So there are three main
tenants around service mesh.
So if I look at the
three key benefits
that service mesh
provide, it's effectively
uniform observability.
It is operational agility.
This is the ability
to migrate traffic,
do circuit breaking, retries
within your environment,
and then policy-driven security.
So this is from a
microservices environment.
All your nice, freshly migrated
VM workloads into containers,
you can start applying these
tenants straight away out
of the box.
So let's drill into
these just a little bit,
and then I'll do a little bit
of a demonstration on service
management.
So one of the things that
service mesh provides
is it provides uniform
metrics and flow logs
across your entire environment.
When we deploy a
container into Kubernetes
we use a Istio sidecar
injector to basically
automatically inject a sidecar
co-located in every pod
associated with that service.
The advantage of doing that
is, in a language agnostic way,
I now get a very consistent
set of metrics and flow
logs through my
entire environment.
I can use them as
golden signals.
I can use them to get an
understanding of these service
dependencies that I have
within my environment.
These service
dependencies can literally
give you a way to understand
how your services are connected.
And this is actually based
on the traffic flows that
is going through your mesh.
The last thing
you can do is, now
I have these really, really
nice uniformed consistent flow
logs and metrics, I can use
them as my golden signals
to set up SLOs on
those services.
I can look at the
service dependencies
to understand what my critical
customer user journey is
with respect to what's
going to impact my end
SLA to my customers.
The other key thing that
we actually look at here,
within a service mesh, is
the ability to add agility.
So there's two things here.
One here is around the ability
to shift traffic or split
traffic.
Canary would be a
good example of this.
I can move, based on a
weighting, a certain amount
of traffic from one
service to a newer version
of that service [INAUDIBLE].
There was a talk
earlier this week
where a customer using
Istio has increased
the number of roll-outs
from around one a day
to on target to
15,000 this year.
And the main reason they're
able to do that is they're
now incrementally releasing
multiple times a day
in very small increments.
That's doing two things.
That is actually
reducing the risk
because every change
is incremental,
and they've got very
fine-grained controls on how
they canary those releases.
This is shortening
the time it takes
for them to get their changes
out to their customers, which
is really important.
The other key thing
that Istio provides
is the ability to do things
like circuit breaking.
I can do retries.
I can build this into the
infrastructure itself.
So if my VM application
that I've just
migrated to
containers didn't have
any of that sort of
capability built into it,
I can now start picking
up these capabilities just
from the service
mesh infrastructure.
The last thing is
around security.
So with Istio or service
mesh, I can effectively
apply a identity-based security
model between my services.
So I can migrate my
services, and I can actually
pick that up straight away.
I can also start looking
at that interconnect
and start getting
security insights.
So let's just take two minutes
and have a quick look at what
that actually looks like.
So I actually have a
microservice application
running.
And these are the
services that are actually
operational within
the actual mesh.
Let me just make that--
can everyone see
that OK or do I need
to make a little bit bigger?
It's OK?
All right.
So what I can actually do
here is I can go through,
and I can quickly look at the
actual topology associated
with this particular
environment.
So I understand the
service dependencies.
I can highlight a
specific service
and understand the
actual traffic that's
traversing this environment.
If I was to click
on that service,
I can go to the
service dashboard
and look at that
particular service.
You'll notice, on this
particular service,
I have not set any SLOs.
One of the things
you'll also notice
is I automatically have
security recommendation.
So then this particular service,
I have not enabled MTLS.
The flow logs and metrics has
given me that information,
and it's giving me
now a recommendation
of how I can
increase the security
posture of my environment.
So these are the things
that the service mesh
can provide for you
straight out of the box.
And this can now
be applied directly
to those VMs workloads that
have been migrated directly
into GKE.
I get very consistent,
these nice flow
logs and metrics associated
with the services
that I've now just migrated.
I can start doing things like
set SLOs on these services.
So setting an SLO, very simple.
Pushing through, selecting,
say, availability
would be an example SLO.
95.4.
Actually, that would
be pretty impressive.
You can actually do this based
on a rolling period of time
or a calendar period
of time, depending
on whether you're setting
something up more for internal
or more to match a
business objective.
Windowing can also be
optionally added with respect
to applying now an
alert associated
with a smaller period of time.
And it would literally just
be as simple as applying that,
and now I actually
have an SLO set
for that particular service.
So that's just kind
of a little bit of a--
if you think about, again,
what Lucien demonstrated,
he migrated VM workloads
straight to Kubernetes.
If you migrate those
VM-based workloads
into a Kubernetes
cluster that has
service management or
a service mesh enabled,
this then just effectively
just works out of the box.
So at this point, I'd
actually like to pause
and invite Leon up to
talk a little bit more
in technical detail
around Anthos Migrate.
And I will hand it over.
Thank you.
LEONID VASETSKY:
Thank you, David.
So I'd like to
give you a glimpse
of inner insights of how it
works, where we're heading.
So this is a very young product.
So we are just starting.
It's a long journey.
And I want to show you
what we're doing now
and what we're doing next.
But before that, I'd like
to give you a little bit
of history, back to
the history lane.
So let's think of the developer,
the application developer that
work on application five
years ago, maybe 10 years ago.
Right.
So he was writing
code, and then he
wanted to run it in an
[INAUDIBLE] way, probably
bundled with contained some
runtime, like Java or Python
maybe.
And he wanted to
put it somewhere.
And the best place to put it,
in [INAUDIBLE] way, was VM.
And this was convenient,
powered by VMware
was extremely popular, so every
application that you write
ended up being with this
stack on the left side.
And you only need application
maybe two or three services
around it, but you were getting
the virtual hardware that you
need to manage, and network,
and disks, and operating system
with kernel and staff, and all
the infrastructure that you
need to accommodate, like
logs, and security policies,
and users that can access it.
So all this is a good start.
But then you're starting
to get more of those.
And specifically, the painful
that those application
[INAUDIBLE] mentioned, small or
mid-sized stateful application,
maybe simple database,
web, middle-tier apps,
they started accumulated.
This can be within apps
for some on some enterprise
or maybe off-the-shelf
applications that you managed.
And this is very, very painful
and become very, very painful.
Now imagine, today, you
are a container developer.
So you can develop your
application packages
in a Docker container and
run it with Kubernetes.
So today, if you
develop a new one,
you have a way of doing that.
But what will you do
with all this leftovers?
And this is a very,
very painful rewrite.
So what we wanted to do is
a phased approach or phased
journey for those
legacy applications
to get to the modern
way, and they're not
number of stops in the middle.
And these stops can
help you benefit
from some of the ecosystem,
maybe not all of this,
and then you can benefit
from more and more.
So the first one,
the first stop,
the one that you all
actually saw in the demo
that we, to the application,
we didn't change anything
for this application, but we
peeled away all the low level
stuff that is not required for
this application to function.
It's required, but it's not must
to be the same stuff in the VM.
So we took away OS
kernel and drivers.
Now it's provided by a container
as orchestration framework.
We took away logging.
We took away networking.
Networking is now
handled by Kubernetes.
We took away storage.
And we leave application and
the services that you may have,
maybe some cron jobs for
this application to run.
So this is the first step.
It allows you to
get into the stage
when you manage the
Kubernetes, leverage all
these good features
that you have,
but it's still not the
end of the journey.
The next bar is going
to this stage, where
we want to take this upper part
of the VM and split it further.
Maybe some application
will be rewritten,
some of our application
will be just
breaking down to the
application and the data.
And maybe some
application will be
left as is because
you don't find it cost
effective to invest in them.
And so this is the
journey that we follow.
And the beta will
cover mostly this far,
then this part will come preview
right pretty much after that.
So this is one aspect.
The second aspect, which
is also very important,
is how you're
doing your journey.
So we focused in all the
demo and announcements,
we focused on getting workloads
from VMware to GKE, right?
But basically there
are two dimensions
that you need to handle.
One is migrating things
from remote location
to another location, can be
either cloud, can be VMware,
again, on-prem data center.
And maybe you don't
need to migrate at all.
If you're moving from
VMware to GKE On-Prem
you don't need to
migrate the data.
The data is already there.
So there's dimension number one.
Dimension number two is
basically moving from the VM
to the container.
So we build product in a
way, and built architecture
in a way, that you can do
any of those transitions
independently.
We can get you, of course,
the quick way, this one,
when you move from
VMware to GKE and cloud,
getting all the benefits.
But you can go either way.
You can first most
GCE VM and then
decide to containerize
this VM and so on.
And this is very important
in that both of those
are handled by the product.
And it's different types and
different places on the road
map when we go there.
But this is
important flexibility
that you want to do.
And especially with Kubernetes,
when you have the storage
obstructions.
So from Kubernetes perspective,
you consuming storage.
And storage can be
remote or can be local.
If you're consuming
storage, and then running
your workload this
container, it doesn't matter.
You want to use this
Kubernetes obstructions
to hide the storage location.
Obviously, this is just
a recap, small recap,
what happened in the demo,
just to give you a replay.
So Lucien [INAUDIBLE]
presented a corporate user
starting with the VMs on-prem
and connection to them.
Then we moved those VM to
being in containers in GKE.
We started to use
networking of Kubernetes.
So at this point, application
were connecting to the database
by its DNS name and the service,
and right now it's both,
so it can any IP.
You don't need to
manage IP anymore.
You have a load balancer
to get you outside access.
And then once those
are containers,
you can see the logs, you
can see all the benefits
from the Istio, and other
things that David show you.
One thing that Lucien
mentioned as well
is that we do have a technology
a couple of years now,
when we want to, we can migrate
storage from remote locations
to cloud.
And we want to leverage
this technology
when we move storage
for containers
and when we move
VMs to containers.
So we have the
same infrastructure
that can bring storage
from remote locations
to their workloads,
no matter if workloads
are VMs or containers.
And this is how the
product is built.
And again, you can use it
to migrate first, VM as VM,
and then containerized, or
you can go directly to that.
We're talking a
lot about storage.
Why is it so important?
This is where caching,
and latency optimizations,
and deduplication-- all
the things that the storage
layers gives you, Velostrata
storage layer gives you,
they come into play.
And it's the same
optimization that we
use for containers and the VMs.
And this is basically what
gives you the ability to test
something or to run something
in couple of minutes because you
cannot move terabytes of
data in a couple of minutes.
So let's get another
level down of how this
works on the Kubernetes side.
So quick show of hands,
who is familiar with CSI?
That's less.
So I won't go to the CSI here.
It's a lots of
lectures about that.
CSI is container storage
interface, something that
became GA in Kubernetes 113.
Basically, this is
one of the things that
allows you to obstruct
the storage implementation
from the orchestration.
So Kubernetes will orchestrate
the workload creation
and will orchestrate
the volume provisioning,
volume attachment.
And then you will
be, as a driver,
as the provider of
the storage, you
will be providing the
implementation for that.
So what will happen?
When you deploy the [INAUDIBLE]
that Lucien showed you, you
actually trigger the activity
from Kubernetes, which says,
OK, I need to schedule
this pod on this node,
and I need to make
sure that this node has
access to storage.
And you ask me for the
storage of this type,
so I need provisioning.
So at this point, Kubernetes
goes to the storage driver
and ask me, OK, look, I need
to provision the storage.
This can be native
storage driver.
For some storage
vendor it can be
native storage driver
for GCE persistent disk
or, in our case
of the streaming,
Velostrata Control Plane.
It basically says, look, if I
have a needed provision volume,
I'm exposing the storage of
this VM from on-premise or other
[INAUDIBLE] to this cluster.
So Kubernetes is happy,
volume is provisioned,
now he decide which node
should be used to run pod,
and then it's come
in attachment.
So he connects this node
to the storage backend,
mounts relevant volumes.
And at this point,
the workload that runs
consumed this storage, again,
being it remote or local.
What's important in that
system, so it's fully integrated
with Kubernetes obstruction.
It means that if you want
just to migrate the storage,
and you don't want
to migrate your VM,
just maybe you already have
MySQL container, MySQL image
that you want to use, you
only want to move the data,
then you will do the same.
So you will attach the storage
to the existing container,
and it will benefit from the
same streaming and compression
technology.
And last, what you can
also do with the storage--
and this is something
that we're also providing.
This is what we call optimized
data, data extraction,
or selective data extraction.
So we provide the job in
the Kubernetes cluster--
again, fully managed
by Kubernetes,
fully obstructed by
Kubernetes obstruction-- that
can take you're
streaming storage
and extract part of the files of
part of the data that you want.
For example, you only want
your MySQL database data.
So this will fetch this
storage in a streaming manner
inefficient with all
the optimization,
and it will deploy it to the
storage of your choosing.
It can be native
cloud storage, it
can be storage vendor
that runs in the cloud.
And this is also a foundation
of what we call the next phase.
So this is the same
technology that
will then be used to
extract the application.
So let's say you have
multiple services running
on the same VM, and you want
to extract some of them,
so we'll extract part of
the data will go here,
part of the data will go there.
And this will be the same
component doing this job.
So with that, I'll heading back
to Lucien for a quick wrap-up.
LUCIEN AVRAMOV:
Thank you, Leonid.
[APPLAUSE]
So what did we learn?
Well, hopefully, I hope that
you understand, first of all,
that modernization is no
longer something where
it means you have to rewrite
everything from scratch.
And it means that if
you want to go there,
we're here to help
you on this journey
with moving those application
on a modern environment.
Two, I hope you understand
that state stateful apps can
actually run now in GKE without
any need for writing them
again.
It's kind of the same
as the first point.
And then number three,
this can be directly done
from on premise to
the cloud, and you can
be up and running in minutes.
Now, one thing to
remember is we don't
have to migrate you directly
to containers and to the cloud
if you're on premise.
We can do it in two steps.
We can move you to the cloud
on a VM, get you comfortable,
and then move that
VM to a container.
OK.
So we can meet you
in your journey
where you are, and
this comes back
to some of the questions
on the Dory today
where one question was,
well, how about Windows?
Can I use Anthos
Migrate for Windows?
Well, what we can do today
with Anthos Migrate for Windows
is VM-to-VM migration.
So we can get you to the
cloud running as a VM,
and when we have support
for Windows on GKE--
hopefully later this year--
then we can migrate that
VM into a container.
Number two, another question
on the Dory was, well,
is Velostrata a requirement
of Anthos Migrate?
Anthos Migrate is Velostrata.
It's the same thing.
You install Velostrata, and
you can do VM-to-VM migration,
and now you can do
VM to GKE migration.
So hopefully that clears it up.
I've put some links on the deck.
So if you download
this, you have
the list of all our resources,
public documentation.
We have a couple of
other sessions-- one more
this afternoon that
will be interesting.
I think the other
ones have past,
but you can watch
the recordings.
We're at the booth all day.
Stop by the Infrastructure
and Modernization booth
to talk to us.
We can do live demos, talk
further on your environment.
And finally, in the last 10
seconds, just to let know,
give us feedback-- what you
liked, what you didn't like.
If you want us to come
back again and talk more,
if you don't want to see
us again, let us know.
But we really take it seriously.
So thank you very much,
and have a good conference.
[APPLAUSE]